hi there steve kaufman
we are now approaching
or starting
week 4 of this 12-week course
this 12-week
concentrated effort to achieve a
breakthrough in the language and i have
spoken about the importance of doing
something every day
the importance of varying your
activities the fundamental importance of
listening because listening
comprehension
is to my mind the most important skill
with good listening comprehension you
read better
you get to speak better so you need to
do a lot of listening and listening is
easy to fit into your schedule but today
i want to talk about
linking linking is sort of the unique
function at link lingq link when we say
linking we mean creating links we mean
if you're on your ipad with a stylus
you know pointing out a word or clicking
on a word
in order to see first of all what it
means now remember
the meaning of the word we call it a
hint because a word can have different
meanings in different contexts the
dictionary definition sometimes is not
relevant to the text that you are
looking at
and so that this hint is sort of a start
it helps you
you know
start the process of getting a sense of
what a word means how it's used with
which other words what's the full scope
of the meaning and when you look a word
up don't uh you know
in depending on the language you're
learning
uh
and
your you know your native language there
are a variety of dictionaries that you
can hook up to at link
so
choose one that you like and i tend to
use several different dictionaries
because
they provide different services if you
want sometimes i just use hints that
other people have chosen don't forget we
cash
we store
hints that other people have selected so
that you needn't go to the dictionary
but sometimes that's not the hint or the
meaning that you want for a particular
context and so very often i go to other
dictionaries
and dictionaries can sometimes have
different interpretations of words so
it's useful to look at different
dictionaries and i tend to rely on those
dictionaries that i find the best
and
you know
very often in say romance languages
where you know
verb endings tenses or
declensions in slavic languages
are things that causes difficulty and so
then there are some dictionaries that
are better than others at showing us
uh you know for example context reverso
is very good in this regard so you'll
see the verb you'll see where it fits in
you'll see what the conjugation is so i
like to have these different resources
that i can use when i you know create a
link and look up a word
uh you can tag
your links
you can look up sort of the grammatical
sometimes in some of the languages we
tell you this is a noun and then you can
look up
in our grammar resources how nouns or
verbs function in that language so there
are lots of bits of information you can
get when you create a link
now the next thing about creating links
is that you have now started or you've
added these to your database of words
and phrases so
uh
even though you won't remember the first
time you look up a word the next time
you see that word
which was blue
generally speaking when you created that
link it's not yellow it's now yellow and
it's a darker yellow and gradually moves
to a lighter and lighter shade of yellow
as you get a better and better sense of
the meaning of that word
once you've created a link you can now
review these links in flashcards
dictation
fill in the blanks multiple choice the
different activities that we have
and here again
i like to do this when i move from page
to page in
when i'm reading a lesson of link but
other people like to do it in the
vocabulary section uh using this based
repetition model that we have so there
are a variety of ways in which once
you've created these links you can then
review them and get a better handle on
on these and try to remember them
so and links also when you create links
not only is the number of links you
create an indication of your activity
level because you should be creating
links i create links even if i kind of
half know the meaning of the word i link
it
and sometimes
when i have moved a word to known
either because i manually did so
or i never saved it initially because i
thought i knew the meaning of the word
and then i'm not so confident anymore
any word that has already moved to white
you can link it again and just the
statistics adjust so my goal is to make
my my page at length lighter and lighter
in color blue becomes yellow yellow
becomes white but sometimes a word has
moved to white
uh
prematurely and then i just link it
again so i'm uh you know i don't
hesitate to create links and creating
links is an indication that you are
active and the more active you are
the faster you are going to learn and of
course creating links helps the system
guess
and what you know because words that you
don't link that you encounter blue words
that you encounter that you don't link
the system assumes that you know and so
you get this known words total gradually
drawing and again it's not scientific
ideally
uh like link will not save numbers so
that doesn't add to your known words
total and if it's a place name or a
personal name and you or a word in
another language
then you use the x
to ignore it or you can do that with
your cursor
and in that way it's not added to your
total but the known words total again is
a rough indicator of your progress in
the language it's a rough indicator of
your activity level it's not a
scientific number but it also depends on
you creating links so there are many
many reasons why you should be actively
creating links both of words and phrases
as a big part of your learning activity
so
starting on week four let's get out
there and create a lot of links